[Applause]
hi i am so happy to be here
i'm so happy that you came on the show
and i am very excited to be speaking to
a fellow host
how are you liking the job i love it
this is what i've
always wanted to do and i think acting
just got me here
i just love connecting and so it just
falls into my wheelhouse and i'm having
a ball i love working with lonnie and
adrian and jeanie mai i mean we really
have
great conversations and um we have a
really great sisterhood which is really
lovely
do you feel like because it's called the
real that there's a responsibility to
keep it real
and are you really allowed and
encouraged to keep it real or are there
boundaries
i don't do anything but keep it real
that's my thing but yeah for sure we
keep it real and
what's great is that we can have
disagreements we can have different
opinions which is what makes it
fascinating and and fun because i may
think a certain way
they might might not yeah
well and those shows uh are really about
your opinions and your thoughts and your
experiences your life
experiences exactly and boy do i have
them
well it's a perfect segue into
coming to america too i mean
listen i cannot believe it we shot
this over 30 years ago i was the mayor
of
embryo
i mean the fact that we're back i mean
everybody's back arsenio eddie murphy
sherry headley vanessa bell calloway i
mean we are
we were together on a set again wearing
these amazing elaborate costumes
it's really exciting and i got to see it
a couple of weeks ago and it's really
good
it's one of my favorite movies of all
time and
i am very excited i've already seen
pictures of you and your beautiful
dresses you look
extraordinary thank you
well this is what we all need right now
so
thank you garcelle you're welcome drew
okay the book series that you have
called the i
am series there is i am
living in two homes i am mixed i am
awesome and
i have uh kids you know who
go back and forth and so i was
very intrigued uh that you put this out
there because i don't believe we're
alone
and i think it's really great for people
to be able to have something to turn to
to not only feel less alone but
get some wisdom from that experience why
did you decide to put
that out there um you know what the book
series the i am book series came through
a need that i felt like i was when i had
the boys
we i couldn't find any books that spoke
on diversity or
where they saw characters that look like
them so we started with the i am mixed
because my kids are mixed
and then i am living into home happened
to be what they were going through going
and they still go through
it was important for them to know that
no matter what home they're in that
we're still a family
and that we and that it's important for
them to know that we're doing the best
we can
and they're come from love and the
family is not going anywhere even though
we're not living in two homes
so i really wanted to put a positive
spin on it and uh and it's helped a lot
of
a lot of parents transitioning through
you know the co-parenting of it all
yeah and i uh you know am in that
as well and so seeing your book series
and particularly the i am living in two
homes
we you know figured we were not the only
two women and there are other women out
there that have to deal with the same to
home lifestyle
[Music]
you